the jurogan experience you know
i've gone through again all these
iterations of trying to
um assist people with the information
that i've come across
in my research on how they can achieve
an ideal body composition have more
energy
maintain or build you know muscle
improve their immune systems have better
sex be more productive whatever it is
these are the things that these are what
i'm trying to um
the the hidden genetic switches that i'm
trying to uncover for people
and in in so doing you can choose to do
it or not i'm not suggesting you have to
do this to have a
great life but here are some of the ways
we do it and it started with a primal
blueprint
and then sort of morphed into well the
primal blueprint works really well for a
lot of people
and even worked well for me but is there
something else is there a new
like level i could get to and that was
the keto so i
wrote a book called the keto reset diet
since i was on here and i was i was in
the keto for a while but then i
i sort of said well you know ketosis is
not a way to live
your life it's a it's a tool a strategy
that you can use to build metabolic
flexibility
some people do think that it's a way to
live your life though like
you know dom dogostino yeah he he does
it all the time
yeah i mean i have a lot of friends who
do who do keto the whole time i'm just
i'm not a person who says that's the way
keto is the you know
the be all and the end all of how you
should live your life because i'm
i'm more about achieving metabolic
flexibility and
and that's a term that's come up in the
last couple of years i don't know if
you've heard it but it basically
describes your body's ability to extract
energy from whatever substrate is
available at the time
so making it easier for your body to
balance back and forth from fat to
carbohydrates did not require so much of
a gap bingo because usually the gap is
what is like two weeks or something like
that for you if you're
a carbohydrate yeah and if you're and if
and if you never
go down the route of keto and all you do
is eat carbs your whole life or have a
carb-centric diet
you never get to the point where you're
burning fat efficiently or effectively
so you're really metabolically
inflexible your body is just demanding
that it continuously run on carbs and
never tap into your fat stores
so you get typically you get
incrementally fatter and fatter
and then if you skip a meal or skip two
meals or try to go on
some sort of a fast the wheels fall off
because you haven't built a metabolic
machinery to burn fat to burn ketones
and and all the things that go along
with with metabolic flexibility so
it turns out metabolic flexibility is
the holy grail
and how you get there whether it's uh
primal
paleo uh vegetarian
vegan uh fasting if whatever
i don't it's almost like it's it doesn't
matter what route you
you use if you can get to the point
where you're metabolically flexible
now you have this ability to to extract
energy from your own stored body fat
whenever you don't eat and how does one
do that like what's the best strategy
well the best strategy is keto
so that's the best for sure for sure
that's the best strategy
so um because uh as long as you keep
feeding your body carbohydrates every
two or three hours all day long
the body goes hey i got i got plenty of
fuel
taking the carbohydrates in raises my
blood sugar
blood sugar is a fuel but i don't want
too much of it in my system and so
the body produces insulin which tries to
take
excess glucose and protein and fat out
of the bloodstream and sequester it in
the cells
and in so doing your blood sugar drops
because it's it's and then you have to
eat again every two or three hours and
it's this cycle that people enter into
that they that they're on for
a lifetime sometimes and and the
tendency over time
because you're not burning your stored
body fat is to accumulate body fat you
never get really
adept at burning body fat and you never
because you never take
time off to require that your body burns
its fat
you just keep accumulating it
so how does someone go from being
metabolically inflexible to
metabolically flexible
without going into keto that's difficult
the way to do it is is through
fasting um and it's just keto is such a
better way to do it and the reason is
you you're trying to
prompt the body into making changes that
it doesn't want to make
you know when you go to the gym and you
lift weights you're prompting
the body to build muscle that it really
doesn't want to build but now you're
you know you're giving it a reason to
and so when you withhold carbohydrate
from the diet and
sugar in particular but carbohydrate in
general and the body senses that it's
not going to get glucose for a while
it starts to go to a plan b
which is to build the metabolic
machinery to start to extract energy
from
stored fat cells to burn that fat to
combust
that fat in the muscle cells it takes
some of the fat sends it to the liver
and to convert into ketones because the
brain works really well on ketones
in fact the brain works better on
ketones than it does on
glucose for most people so the body has
this
built-in plan this diagram this genetic
program that you're born with
to be metabolically flexible and to be
able to extract energy from
fat and from ketones and from glucose
uh and and it would normally go that
route but we
we never give it the reason to now how
is that
plan how has it evolved well for most of
human history
we ate and we didn't eat it wasn't like
you know breakfast was the most
important meal of the day or make sure
you keep
you know uh little tupperware things of
uh
a little bit of protein and some
carbohydrate to eat every two or three
hours or else your muscles go into
cannibal mode
no humans are wired to overeat
and because food was so scarce when we
did come across food we tend to
to eat more and certainly sweet foods
like fruits was even
more palatable so we probably tended to
eat more of that
but but so we're wired to overeat and we
have this amazing
design that allows us to take excess
energy
and convert it into fuel that we carry
around
with us all the time conveniently
located
above the center of gravity so it's on
the hips on the butt on the
thighs on the belly so so we tend to
carry this
excess body fat as a survival mechanism
from
a million years ago that's why you carry
it here yeah
that's sure that it's like like a fanny
pack
yeah it's exactly what it is that's
exactly what it is so so
but again if you look at evolution and
how and how things you know work we're
bipedals we have to stand up right so
you know if we had uh fat accumulating
on our
upper back or whatever we'd be you know
tipping over
so it's conveniently located over the
center it's an elegant elegant design
the problem is it was designed so that
when you didn't eat
food you could take that same fuel take
it out of storage combust it
and and not be any of the worse for wear
not think of anything
other than you know i'm still gonna hunt
i'm still gonna do all these things
i haven't eaten for five days i'm not
hangry
i'm not pissed off at my mate i'm just
gonna keep going with a great attitude
that i'm gonna find something
to eat now what is the standard amount
of time is there a standard amount of
time between if a person
eats a normal american diet and they
just decide to fast
how long does it take before their body
to
converts to burning fat
if they're not going keto right yeah um
they're probably gonna burn they're
gonna probably use a little bit of
muscle in the process
because the body if it isn't used to to
uh deriving most of its energy from fat
because of a process that you've engaged
in
to to use keto to you know
to burn fat um it'll it'll still seek
glucose and if you don't give it glucose
and you haven't done this work
for the first couple of days it's it's
miserable and so people talk about the
low carb flu
or the um or you know if they go on a
fasting thing at an ashram you know i
saw
i saw elvis you know two days ago pelvis
whatever yeah yeah whatever
i was in my in my dreams oh you're
saying because you're going crazy
because you're going crazy
right so you're you know your your your
brain is kind of frazzled because you
haven't
given it the opportunity to to really
thrive on ketones yet
your body's making ketones but you
haven't again you haven't built that
metabolic machinery
to use them efficiently and effectively
and so the brain's still looking for
glucose
and as a result what happens is the
brain will send a signal to
the adrenals to secrete cortisol
cortisol then you know
goes throughout the body and strips
amino acids from muscle tissue
to send them to the liver to become
glucose so you can feed the brain
so it's it's counterproductive over time
and it's also
you know one of the reasons why back in
the old bodybuilding days in the old in
the old
training days in any gym this this
mantra about don't go more than three or
three or four hours without eating or
you'll cannibalize your muscle tissue
if you haven't become fat adapted and
keto adapted that
does happen you do cannibalize muscle
tissue when you
go long periods of time without eating
like say when i say standard american
diet i don't mean
junk food but if you're a person who
eats normal you eat a little bit of
pasta a little bit of bread
but you eat mostly healthy if you decide
that you're going too fast
your body's going to cannibalize some
muscle not so much
yeah how much a few pounds not even you
know a few pounds maybe a few pounds and
you get it back
you'll get it back but the idea is that
if you can weather that storm
how much time are you looking for before
your body starts burning fast some
people
a week some people two weeks a week some
people three weeks you'll be dead
you can't fast for two weeks oh no
you're talking about fasting fasting oh
jesus no i'm talking about uh no i'm not
talking about no no i'm talking no no
i'm talking about intermittent
no that gets us to two meals a day right
so but what if someone
just fasts but so what so give me a term
like okay
so if you decide yeah i'm gonna go on a
36 hour fast
that's probably the high end of what i
would do and then anything
beyond that i'd be a little bit
concerned that i hadn't prepped myself
with with fat adaptation yet so when
people go on these crazy three to five
day fasts
they report all this energy they feel
great they feel amazing
what's going on there well they're
they've got their brains are using
ketones right so that's
definitely where the energy the feeling
of amazing comes from
um typically if you're fasting that long
you're not working out
like like any of these like my wife does
a
seven day water fast oh geez twice a
year oh jesus that's what i said
do you go on vacation when that's
happening no i eat more i eat for her
why does she do that she has this you
know she feels
that like it's uh good for her she's
into the autophagy and the and
and some of the um explain anti-aging
it burns cells that are yeah so this
when you're one of the things one of the
many things that happens when you when
you fast is that your body
goes into a different mode and it starts
to realize there's not going to be a lot
of
fuel around for a while and so in
addition to burning
stored body fat in addition to making
ketones
by the way ketones come from fat so some
of the fat that you combust is also just
converted into ketones that your brain
can use
um it also the body also says
like if you were to be a if you had a
brain if you were a cell and you had a
brain he thought well
generally there's a lot of fuel around
so my job is to pass the genetic
material along to the next generation so
there's plenty for two of us so i'll
just divide there'll be two of us
that'll be great
that same cell when in the absence of of
this sort of bathing in in nutrition
goes
well this is not even enough for one of
me let alone two of me so i'm not going
to divide
i'm going to repair what i have and so
the cell goes into a repair process
where it starts to consume damaged
proteins and damaged fats
within itself uh it it and it actually
gets energy from that
um starts to repair uh broken strands of
dna or whatever little things are going
on it actually kills off
senescent cells at that time so it's a
it's an anti-aging strategy that a lot
of people use
um it's also a god i hate the term reset
i gotta
why do you hate the term because it's
overused no but
and i used it in a book but all of a
sudden in the context of what's going on
in the world
and the great reset like i never want to
hear that term again oh the great reset
isn't that that's the conspiracy theory
that the government is using this to
change the financial structure of the
country
and everything else yeah do you hear
that a lot in florida is that what's
going on no no no
no no no no no no no we don't know but i
read a lot joe
i read the new york times to see what
the other side's doing yeah
but um so so she
she will do these fast but she's
metabolically flexible so it's easy for
her to do
but if you're not metabolically flexible
and you try you you
you take on a fast of three days
um you can get through it and and it's
probably good for you
my whole thing is i want this to be if
you chose to do something like that i
wanted to be
pleasurable pleasurable and easy and
graceful and you know something you look
forward to doing not something you
dread doing now is there um amount
can you intermittent fast and get your
body to be more metabolically flexible
in that way yeah that's and that's what
i'm talking about so so
i'm not even into the multi-day fasting
i'm into
um two meals a day so the premise of the
book
is um once you've developed metabolic
flexibility
to engage in as much time as you can
of not eating throughout the day to
maximize all of these
benefits that we just described that
come from not eating and
one of the things we say is most of the
good things happen
to us when we're not eating you know
most repair most recovery most of
rebuilding
happen when we're not eating when we're
eating which we have to do
um it comes with inflammation and and
you know it's a it's a necessary thing
but the good stuff all happens when
we're not eating so to the extent that
we can
we can expand that window of not eating
and with
with the two meals a day program and
which pretty much anybody who's keto now
does
you just have an evening meal and then
you don't eat until
one o'clock 1 30 2 o'clock the next day
so you have two meals a day
and you have that 18-hour window that's
your that's what you use
an 18-hour window yeah why did you
choose 18
um it works for me i mean you can do 16
you can do i mean anything less than
you know 14 is back to sort of you know
where you were before it's a little bit
better but it's not as
like i said the more time that you can
go between eating the better and it and
it isn't about a
uh so much a routine on a daily basis
it's basically um uh i certainly use
that as a template but once in a while i
eat one meal a day i'll go you know
dinner to dinner to dinner
and the the beauty here is because i'm
metabolically flexible i have the
confidence
that i'm not tearing down muscle tissue
i have
that my immune system is probably
benefiting from it as opposed to being
somehow hurt by it i maintain muscle
mass
again i have all this energy and most
importantly i'm not hungry
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience